families and friends gather together to
watch grown men beat the crap out of
each other i thought that was going to
have a different ending but that's what
thanksgiving is all about it's about
sitting around watching football so you
don't have to interact with your family
members i mean that's why
right that's that those awkward moments
when people who only see each other a
couple of times a year are crammed into
a room and everybody kind of assumes
that role that they had years ago and
the best way to avoid all of that is
turn on the tv and watch a football game
chris well i don't know how it works in
your family we enjoy being together in
the same room so i don't know but either
way oh we we do too i'm just talking
about the typical american family i'm
glad to not be in that mainstream but
what i hear from others all the time is
my god i i wish i didn't have to do this
for the next two days uh it's my
favorite holiday of the year i mean it
beats christmas in my opinion you don't
have to buy gifts and do all that crap
okay yeah it's not to do anything for
other people yeah the hell with that
let's just enjoy each other and not make
it about the gifts and anything like
that but i mean eating food watching
football uh you know on a fall day i
don't know it just doesn't get any
better than that to me i mean three
great games and like traditional power
games that's what i love right there i
mean i love bears lions cowboys redskins
that just seems thanksgiving to me you
know saints saints falcons of course is
a good rivalry but it's a new age
rivalry it doesn't have the history the
lions bears redskins cowboys has but
three awesome games regardless and
um really i i you know of course we know
the saints are the best team in football
i don't think there's any team that look
at this and just go oh this is a slam
dunk win on thursday either it's gonna
be three close football games and i
think that will add to the thanksgiving
flavor
all three games rematches of games
previously played all three games
involving division rivals and this has
been a trend in recent years all three
games
from the nfc not a single afc team
playing on
thanksgiving and let's start with the
first game of the day the bears taking
on the lions for the second time in 11
days the bears played sunday night they
had to turn it around and play
essentially thursday morning their time
and mitchell trubisky he didn't practice
monday now nobody practiced monday on
the bears that's that crazy injury
report we see every week where there
wasn't a practice this is an estimation
of who would have practiced or wouldn't
have practiced if we did practice and we
didn't practice and mitchell trubisky
wouldn't have practiced if we had
practice but nobody practiced on tuesday
it was more specific the bears practiced
trubisky didn't he's got a problem with
his throwing shoulder the lion's
preparing for the system not so much the
quarterback the bear is holding out hope
he can play it's a fairly significant
difference chris if it's going to be
mitchell trubisky or chase daniel
tomorrow for the bears yeah it
definitely will be and i think the first
thing you talk about i mean trubisky his
scrambling some of the runs he had in
the first matchup were extremely
impressive you know i don't look at this
and go oh the bears the bears who are
one of the better running teams in
football you know this is the one point
i'd make hey they're still a good
running football team but since the
lions got damon snacks harrison and
after that first game against the
seattle seahawks where he had about four
days to practice their run defense has
been phenomenal i look at these matchups
mike where you know you just mentioned
it's the second time they've played in
11 days the bears had some success in
the pass game kind of tore up the map
patricia scheme they cracked the code as
you and i say sometimes
i look at that as being an advantage to
the lions because the bears are gonna
look at the film and go okay this worked
that worked okay
you know we're happy with our offensive
performance maybe there's a wrinkle or
two here but matt patricia goes well our
defense got totally torched in the past
game we have to change some things up
there and that's where i think their
defense does have an advantage going
into a matchup like this but either way
i expect this to be a close game chase
daniel or trubisky at quarterback
yeah and here's the thing about the
lions you know they don't win every
thanksgiving and and
they you know they've had plenty of bad
teams over the years but i think that in
any given year whatever the lions are
you're going to get the best version of
that lions team on thanksgiving right if
they're good that year they're going to
be great on thanksgiving if they're bad
that year
except they had like a blowout loss to
the patriots one season i remember and i
think the titans were were you on that
title
right yes i i think your point still uh
holds you know holds water as they say
for sure the lions have been competitive
on all these thanksgiving days and and
you know with the with a matthew
stafford at quarterback the games have
at least been exciting because you know
he's going to throw the ball all over
the lot now the big thing is for the
lions in this matchup is carry on
johnson's health right mike i mean you
know do we know where he's he flies
right now as far as i know he sprained
his knee last week in the game this is a
week to week week to week which means he
probably ain't playing this week given
that it's a short week that that's
really the issue with this matchup all
together i mean the lions can they
create enough offense on this bear's
defense which is one of the best in
football if you don't have the run game
to kind of keep the bears honest and you
have to become past heavy and pass all
the time
you know hey
that's khalil mack and akeem hicks this
is one of the best fronts in football so
if they have a beat on okay the run
games you know out of the game plan this
week we can focus on the pass that's
where
it'll meet be tough sledding
on the detroit lions offense all
together
they still have legarrette blount though
and one had some comments yesterday
about how it's been a disappointing
season one of the reasons it's been
disappointing is because carrion johnson
has been the better option but if blunt
could muster a performance like those
we've seen from him in the past that
could give the lions the balance they
desperately need offensively and again
we're going to see the best version of
the detroit lions and the best version
of those players even though a lot of
players complain about short week
football there's something different
about the thanksgiving games and the
lions and the cowboys have that wired
into their dna that they will be hosting
those games they'll be playing in those
games and i think the fact that every
team plays a short week game now pretty
much every team plays one except the
really bad teams that they don't want to
put on thursday nights the fact that the
lions and the cowboys have just been
doing it every year i think it's made it
easier for them to adjust to it and the
cowboys will be hosting a division rival
in the middle game up until 2006 there
were only the two games the lions and
the cowboys and they've had the
hammerlock on hosting thanksgiving day
games for decades now and washington and
the cowboys even with alex smith out a
very compelling game a historic game i
remember when i was a kid that was the
first nfl rivalry i noticed that was the
first time i became aware of the concept
of having a rival it was washington and
dallas and i remember the 74 game when
clint longley came in and won the game
for the cowboys and who the heck is
clint longley and just that just so many
intriguing concepts about football that
you learned through that rivalry and i
think it's a great look the stakes
couldn't be any higher first place in
the nfc east is on the line the team
that wins this game probably has the
inside track at winning the division
and a lot riding on it and it ends up
being you know when the schedule came
out okay maybe it's going to be a good
game maybe it's not the eagles are the
class of the division now it's clear the
team that wins this game will be most
likely the division winner yeah it's
certainly going to give somebody a leg
up and and give whoever wins the game a
little momentum i mean just like you
know hey we might see chase daniels for
the bears hey he's been in this offense
under matt nagy in kansas city okay we
got colt mccoy here he's been under jay
gruden for a number of years now
it's going to be about him coming into
the football game and having the deal
with this dallas cowboy defense dallas
defense
as you know as anybody's been watching
football is one of the best in the
league stopping the run i would say the
corner duo of byron jones and chadobia
woozay is as good as any in football
byron jones is in the conversation for
one of the best pure cover corners in
all of football this year the way he's
played can the redskins and colt mccoy
muster up enough offense i think this is
another game i look at it and go it's
going to be defensive struggle for for
my for for my liking mike you know okay
you know i look at that and go okay can
the redskins move the ball in the
cowboys and i flip it over and go how
about the cowboys moving the ball on the
redskins i don't know the first time
they played the cowboys couldn't run the
ball in the redskins and if there's a
weakness to the redskins it's their past
defense
and i don't sit here and go oh the
cowboys have reinvented the wheel on
throwing got cooper right marie cooper
he certainly has helped i just don't
know i don't know how much you know
again it's the scheme so if they can run
the ball and force one-on-one situations
with amari cooper like you're saying
mike that's when they're at their best
uh i just still think the cowboys get a
little pass happy from time to time
we stumbled onto i think the best way to
assess the cowboys while we were
watching the falcons dallas game on
sunday at the nbc viewing room at at the
studio in connecticut the the notion
that you can tell pretty much in the
first five minutes of the game whether
or not the cowboys are going to win
because they have plan a and plan a
works and they win or plan a doesn't
work and there's no plan b c or d and
they lose and we will know i think
halfway through the first quarter
whether or not the cowboys are going to
win the game yeah i i mean they
certainly seem to be a little bit of a
front runner if you've got if you get to
see early on that their
run game is having a little success
that usually bodes well for the rest of
the game to go okay the cowboys offense
isn't going to be inept in this game
altogether uh hey this is going to be
about about the battle up front the
redskins o line is it going to be
totally healthy are we going to have a
trent williams who's missed the last few
games because we know the pass rush for
the cowboys is good they're already
missing people on that redskins o line
to begin with and you know can the
redskins on the other side of the ball
they've had issues on offense with alex
smith so now you got to throw colt mccoy
in on a short week and i don't think
they're going to be able to sit there
and depend on their running game against
this cowboy defense either i think this
is like a defensive struggle a lot like
the first game we saw 20 to 17
17 14 type of football game
and and this will be an opportunity for
adrian peterson right national audience
hey remember me i still can bring it
he's gotten healthier full participant
in practice on tuesday despite that
shoulder injury he's been dealing with
for weeks and i think he's going to
bring it now whether or not he can do
enough that remains to be seen but that
should be a great game let's wrap this
segment by talking briefly about a game
that look very easily could be a blowout
when you see the the saints win 51-14
over the bengals in cincinnati and then
they beat the defending super bowl
champions 48-7 this could be bad news
for the falcons but division rivalries
you throw out the records you throw out
the history you just get together and
you beat the heck out of each other and
when they got together in week three
43-37 the saints won in overtime that
was a back-and-forth classic game that
you know if it would have been a prime
time game it would have been all we were
talking about the next day so now we get
an opportunity to see if the falcons can
keep it close and i think they will keep
it close i saw the spreads like 13 and a
half points i think the falcons are
going to keep this game close well and
they're desperate uh we know that the
the saints defense has been better but i
would expect the falcons be able to
throw the ball on this saints defense
yeah so i i look at it that way and i
think i kind of agree with you are we
ever going to see the saints sleep up i
mean slip up you know are they ever
going to get caught sleeping here with
all these big wins they've had you know
that's the one thing i've been impressed
by the new orleans saints to this point
i mean will will they slip off at slip
up after a big win in baltimore will
they slip up after a sunday night win in
minnesota okay the rams game this might
be the week they let down nope they
don't do it then then they kill the
bengals and the eagles that's what i've
been impressed with the saints they have
played and held themselves to a standard
they have yet to kind of play down to
competition or do anything like that
they seem kind of like an unstoppable
force right now i think like 13 points
is too much i'm with you but the saints
are
clearly in a class of their own as
compared to the falcons right now hi i'm
mike tarico and thanks for watching make
sure to hit subscribe for the latest
news and highlights from nbc sports